well it's hard to think of a tougher or
more important job than being an air
traffic controller go ahead and try
it'll take you a while every day more
than two and a half million Americans
fly in or out of US airports along with
of course many billions of dollars of
cargo at any one time they're about
5,000 aircraft above the United States
at 9/11 for example air traffic
controllers guided every one of them to
a safe landing and a little over an hour
go ahead and try that is the kind of job
or even a small mistake kid leave
instantly to the deaths of hundreds of
people not surprisingly the hiring
standards for air traffic controllers
were long among the most selective of
all Federal jobs applicants typically
needed to complete military service or
pass the FAA s collegiate training
initiative program after that they sat
for a specially-designed exam that
tested for relevant job skill skills
like math ability and complex
problem-solving
only those were the highest scores made
the cut the system was designed to
choose the best and for decades it
worked then during the Obama
administration activists bureaucrats
decided that the pool of air traffic
controllers wasn't diverse enough they
never explained why diversity oughta
matter in air traffic control or why it
was more important than traditional
goals like competence and Public Safety
the faa without a vote just scrapped the
old hiring system and replaced it with a
diversity friendly version most people
have no idea this happened the FAA now
requires many of its applicants to fill
out what they call a biographical
questionnaire before any other screening
those who answer the questions in a way
that diversity monitors don't like
cannot be considered for hiring no
matter how much experience they have or
how well they may do on the other
portions of the testing the biographical
questionnaire is all-important so what
is in this biographical questionnaire we
can answer that question because we got
a copy of it and we also got information
about how it is scored and it's shocking
for example one question asked test
takers to name their worst grade in high
school the preferred answer for that is
science in other words if you can't do
science the FAA is especially eager to
hire you as an air traffic controller
you get 10 points for being bad at
science according to the scoring sheet
another question asked about work
history according to the FAA the best
answer to that question is you haven't
worked at all in the past three years
you get ten points for not working
apparently unemployed people make the
best air traffic controllers this is
demented by the way but it's real
so do applicants who played a lot of
sports in high school they're rewarded
too by contrast applicants who say they
know a great deal about air traffic
control get only five points trained
pilots get two points once again
applicants who haven't worked at all who
have been unemployed for the past three
years get ten points pilots two points
this is insane and it's dangerous it's
also indefensible we asked the FAA is
top spokesman why applicants for an air
traffic control job would get more
points for playing high school sports
than for flying planes are knowing a lot
about air traffic control his response
quote I'm trying to find that out as
well well not actually trying very hard
it turns out we still haven't heard back
with the real explanation and of course
we won't because there isn't one
other than shut up diversity but we
won't shut up this is too important
lives are at stake
joining us now is Michael Pearson he's a
lawyer representing a man who was suing
the FAA for its updated hiring practices
mr. Pearson thank you for coming on why
would the FAA award extra points for
incompetence in science for example well
the biographical questionnaire and
biographical assessment the first
version of it was made to screen out
people with experience it wasn't meant
in any form or function that I can find
and I've been looking at this for almost
four years now including looking over
many documents we had to fight the FAA
for for several years that they kept
hidden to answer that question that the
test was basically meant to screen out
people with aviation experience
there's even worse questions and answers
on the test but you did a pretty good
job of portraying some of the questions
and answers I don't know I don't
understand I mean just to restate for
our audience who was you know so numb to
this kind of thinking that it may not
penetrate we're not talking about hiring
a sociology professor or some other
totally irrelevant
like that talking about air traffic
controllers okay we're the linchpin of
Public Safety and transportation why
would the FAA want people with less
relevant skill in air traffic control
for air traffic controllers because a
group within the FAA including the human
resources function within the FAA
including the national black coalition
of Federal Aviation employees determined
that the work force was too white
they had a concerted effort through the
Department of Transportation the Obama
administration to change that and quite
frankly they're sacrificing and have
sacrificed safety at the altar of
political correctness what happened
offends not only the conscience but also
federal law and we're exposing that but
why would this go on for years without
anybody in elected office saying
anything about it because just once
again and I'm hard to shock because I do
this stuff for a living we are lowering
the standards and intentionally hiring
people who are less competent for one of
the most critical jobs in the federal
government lives are hanging the belt
why would no one in Congress do anything
to stop this well our law firm along
with mountain state's legal foundation
filed the initial lawsuit and then the
group of schools got together over 30
collegiate training institute shouldn't
schools got together and actually went
to Congress and there have been members
of Congress representing Randy Hultgren
representing Frank LoBiondo have
actually held hearings on this the
problem of it is is that the Union natka
controls a large pack and they fund a
lot of politicians and nothing will get
passed an aviation without the blessing
of the controller's union and their
position radically changed when the
Obama administration came in and my
belief is it favors were exchanged now
I'm not saying that lightly I was an air
traffic controller at for the busiest
facilities in the country for almost 27
years along with being an attorney and a
professor so when I say these things
it's not based only on experience it's
also based upon documentary evidence and
proof I have at the end of the day
everyone flies and including members of
Congress who fly quite often and I think
the ones that actually heard this story
were offended by it and because it's in
their backyard it's a safety interest
for them this is not a part as an issue
quite frankly because again it's the
safety of the National Airspace that's a
risk here and I can tell you from
training well over 100 probably 300
controllers of my lifetime as an FAA
controller that there is a difference
this is akin to the Veterans
Administration hiring doctors and trying
to tell the public that the best
physician is one that never went to
medical school and that the VA could
train them better and that's exactly
what's occurred here and quite to be
very straightforward the mainstream
media has covered this has not covered
it actually and it has covered up this
issue and is not revealed what's going
on and it's a shame and it's not only
shameful it again sacrifices public
safety it goes that saying that people
the fa we spoke to were such cowardly
worms and I don't say that lightly
that they wouldn't come on and defend
this but I hope someone forces them to
very quickly in 10 seconds a rhetorical
question did the Obama administration
ever show with data that somehow
increased diversity in the ranks of air
traffic controllers would make the
public safer do they match the case
absolutely not there's published data
out there that says it's a total farce
and in incorrect there's no data to
support that this is social engineering
at its finest
at the sacrifice again of public safety
it's totally demented and we're gonna
ride this until it's made right because
lives are at stake and we're not
overstating it thank you very much
you're knowledgeable the knowledgeable
person on this we appreciate talking